welcome back you never know what's going
to happen here on the five we certainly
aren't unpredictable and Fun Bunch if I
do say so myself so here's a look back
it's of our most memorable moments from
2022.
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell's going on
oh man it's a good thing we're not like
a Broadway
hi Percy this is your debut huge really
huge how huge very huge announcement
about the five is coming up next JoJo
name Pirro is going to be a full-time
co-host on the show and Geraldo Rivera
Harold Ford Jr and Jessica Tarlov will
be our permanent rotating co-host
it's you American voters know exactly
who to trust when it comes to Crime I
like trying to sell portraits when I'm
sitting here I draw Emojis with me see
it matters yeah
coming up next liberal cities
oh yeah that could very well be it
George about made a judge but I'm gonna
be interesting did you call me George do
I owe you money you do okay here you go
I'm not sure if I'm still gonna pay
Heraldo oops that's yours that's not
mine okay
but that's my watch I'll say hello to
Gus Gutfeld all he does is scream in
this demonic whale it's a tiny little
guy today is a holiday that's near and
dear to my heart it is World chocolate
day one side is an Oreo cookie and the
other side is a root stick it's against
nature peanut butter this is Devious
this is the cake so
everyone should be quiet about what they
were just talking about in the
commercial break Dana please hold my
hand oh boy Jesse I hope at this point
that you come up with an analogy that
would make all of us uncomfortable well
no one knows white Suburban women better
than I do I know I'm better than they
know themselves
I was gonna say take Dr Oz
Jesse and my brother you get the nice
case
what exactly happens during the
commercial breaks
what is the inside story
because this one's worth it I agree with
what you said in the green room that we
should be cutting off the hands of
shoplifters
well it's going to be back it's good to
be back
by the way good to see you good to be
back yes we have Shamrock frozen hot
chocolate
[Laughter]
Abigail spamberger Abigail spanberger I
think we should drink every time Dennis
says Abigail spin all right
oh and Carrabba just happened to him he
got it in his bag in his back pocket
very soon we're gonna have our guests of
honor hit that button to light this
sucker up and not in a bad way three two
one
[Applause]
I hope it comes down during Jesse's show
let's do some text messages we're not
crying you're crying um we're crying
with tears of blasters I was talking to
some of the producers this morning and
then talk to them yeah I think they're
wonderful they're so smart control room
don't get mad at me because I know you
said we have to go
sorry I didn't mean to cut you off no
the producer did I heard it
[Music]
oh it shows that we have a lot of fun
during the break
the color yellow spills over
you know what it
they're saying yesterday the great part
of this is that you get to go to work
and do something fun like just have a
conversation with your friends and
that's what's great about the show plus
everybody's so smart other than me
to join the show this year that I saw
that announcement yeah and were we on
boxes
we were this year no last year at the
remember
the beginning
we had little Hugo yeah yeah a little
human and it just has more little here
yes yes we have another one on the way
and uh I got a puppy and he got a puppy
and Greg got a puppy it's a lot of
puppies puppies for everyone
yeah
yeah and it everything is that when you
started your little tear I love when you
can't I've been crying mostly about the
judge recently but it's been fun we had
a great year he meant that nicely like
you're so funny he has to do this oh
like that conversation that was a bad
one the color yellow yeah
right we can never talk about that's
what she said I'm not crying yeah you're
crying the first day that um Jesse was
on I I found that he tears up when he
laughs hard yeah yeah it's one of the
most endearing sweet things that we have
more of that on tape please yes
yeah yeah a lot of stories
yep from The Naked City yep I don't
really know what's going on yeah
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else